the corona virus outbreak hit people
across the world claiming too many lives
it infected the very roots of our
economy and raised many questions about
our healthcare systems and this first
episode of what's left we take a closer
look at the spread of the crisis to the
economy
j'espere o matic angeles that's under me
meet on a measure to monitor Tucson
geometrician see what this crisis might
just be the opportunity to rethink
Europe's current economic model and
here's how
[Music]
as country starting on finding one after
the other economic figures are out and
they're not reassuring the global freeze
of the economy a first in modern history
is set to cause the eurozone to contract
by 7.5 percent this year
the worst recession since the Great
Depression danke nappa Alexa set up a
demo classic which let it he Jenny I
mean I said to Don the mouse the mouse
RAM if you like he's showing self kiss
give especially uphill goofy not the
jobs of up to fifty nine million people
in Europe are at risk
that's almost the entire population of
France beyond the numbers we are talking
about the livelihoods of citizens their
incomes and their plans for the future
that were put in question overnight
there are legislative and budgetary
actions by member states since the
beginning of the crisis however these
measures will affect unevenly Member
States
due to the different spread of the virus
but also to the different structure of
the economy of those days it took a
month of confinement before EU leaders
finally took action as one United block
a common bazooka package amounting to
540 billion euros was agreed on in April
to protect workers businesses and
countries Western actress European only
single Astarte a comet Oliva front data
he's so close to Queen D devarakonda
visa in the longer term all EU countries
will need cash to face the economy
consequences of the crisis in other
words
finance a massive recovery plan if we
take a look at history we may find some
clues to figure out what to do next
in the 1930s to pull his country out of
the depression
Bruce fell decided to take radical
measures he tripled the federal budget
in a few years creating new resources
putting in place a federal tax on
profits and on the richest the first
year it didn't work out
Bruce weld emitted bonds for a few years
and with a massive stimulus package he
stacks plan paid off for today's
progressives this president in history
could give us a way out one tool
governments have in their toolbox to
finance their actions in addition to
taxation is that in normal times all
European countries can issue bonds to
borrow money on the financial markets
but at some point those countries will
have to reimburse the money a financial
markets trust your country they will
lend money easily at low interest rates
lappam Yaqui say tada
yeah the peak you might wish to check
dot said crease sanitaire include a gdp
kemal approach to the public code but
for other countries that only look quite
as stable interest rates can rise this
has a tremendous impact on the country's
ability to restore its economic strength
what might seem like a pretty
insignificant rise in interest rates can
quite quickly turn into billions of
euros to be paid back ESCO control
notice it can be reduced to Chicago not
arbitrated the public control cell
epistemology is a mechanism at a
metropolis on an aphasic national TV
Abinadi GDP repetition is a mechanism of
year total most suited item XE we notice
valid ID in order to avoid this
competition between states and make sure
we have a truly solidarity based
recovery progressives in the European
Parliament but the idea issuing corona
bonds at the European level on the table
in other words a common European debt
shucks be yahoo high capacity on this
mom me to hop on elevator she knows even
power come relation you children me here
don't go went upwards year this is a
bastard mantra this is honey they're
just go see portion on silicon hold
awesome if the EU jointly borrows money
on the financial markets it also needs
to be able to jointly pay back money
borrowed the progressives are pushing to
create new own resources for the EU
budget to create in Devon in revenue for
the EU asking for free on unrecycled
plastics drawing resources from the
European emission straight system
raising income taxes on big corporates
creating a digital services tax but
again place a tax on financial
transactions while making sure the
revenues from tax avoidance and tax
evasion go where the money is needed
[Music]
a few weeks into confinement people woke
up to a world where the air was clean
and where traffic wasn't a nuisance any
more spectacular drops in co2 emissions
were observed
but this doesn't give us the bigger
picture in the last year co2 emissions
have risen more rapidly than in the 60s
and 70s from 0.8 units to Tucanae per
year temperatures continue to rise
everywhere and weather are needed to
deal with the situation
viva la vida loca
imagine a something absolutely ma with
imagining Rosa so now as when a copy
machine nobuta Gilardi in a facility
gravity is familiar phenol so sorry de
la vie so how do we do it how do we
protect citizens jobs and livelihoods
while addressing the biggest challenge
Humanity has probably ever had to face
for the Socialists and Democrats the
path is clear it's called the green new
deal with a just transition at its heart
to ensure that no one is left behind
when we rebuild our economies and our
societies on a sustainable basis and we
do for lost
it was handsome and strong it's thank me
or not
so we can get a better you clean up a
transfer economy in the end progressive
ideas caught the Commission's ear and by
the end of May it proposed the
comprehensive recovery plan 750 billion
euros to support the plucks economies
these investments would come on top of
an existing 1.1 trillion euro wide
budgetary plan the hardest hit sectors
and the most affected regions must be
provided with a lifeline to ensure they
don't have to fight workers or close
down before recovery kicks in the S&D
group will continue putting pressure on
EU leaders so that Europe can live up to
its ambitions siamo since eros el
problema knows
poner más dinero el problema es avanzar
in Europa signora von der Leyen Java
Stoke aqui en el Parliament to repeal
ene un proyecto después tow trabajar
siempre por el bien de la ciudad ania
hora le toca combin ser a los amigos del
consejo se lo de vemos a las próximas
genera fiona's de la nian l-dopa with
the coronavirus crisis we've all been
left in a state of shock first and
foremost was protecting people's health
supporting the most vulnerable in
society and ensuring that workers will
have a job to return to after the end of
the outbreak but then we also woke up to
a new world of possibilities working
from home experimenting new forms of
solidarity and when the clapping stops
and when bit by bit that sense of
normality comes back into our lives what
will we do will we go back to our old
ways or will we embrace real change in
this crisis the progressives will have
fought and pushed for a real change
refusing to sit on the sidewalk of
history while watching Vargas businesses
and our planet go bust now it is time to
be bold and innovative and build a
better future for all stay tuned for
next episode of what's left where we
will explore in more depth how
tomorrow's world could look like
[Music]